Welcome to this lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have looked at how records are stored in database system.
We say we store records basically as bytes streams, but in a way such that we can access every attribute, preferably in constant time.
Like we split it into a, you would see in this example, a fixed sized part and a variable sized part.
and then we store this on a page.
So each slotted page contains multiple tuples, we just store them and the slots allow us to find this.
So this is a standard layout that many database systems use to store their data.
And so this works quite well, we can make it even better by using compression and so on if you want.
It's a trade-off of course with CPU time versus space consumption, but we can do this.
So now the interesting question is, what do we do if we cannot do this?
So now why should we ever not be able to do this?
Remember when we talk about slotted pages, we talk about, in most systems, in 99.9% of
the systems, we talk about systems with a fixed size database page, for example of 16
kilobytes or 32 kilobytes, something like this.
and systems will want to use fixed size pages for a number of reasons.
For example, if you know that all your physical pages are, let's say 16 kilobytes,
then buffer management is easy because you know that you have all this size units that
you can swap in and out.
Recovery is easier because we know that we can, this is the smallest units that we can
recover and so on.
So, your life is much easier if everything is squeezed into pages.
The problem of course is that if you do this, then a tuple must fit in a single page.
So like if you have 16, for example, if my whole page is, this is my whole page, if my
whole page is 16 kilobytes, then obviously I have elusive it because of header and slot
and so on.
Then here I have data and clearly my data D has to be less than 16 kilobytes because
I have some other overheads.
So I kind of make the page completely, it is nearly 16 kilobytes but it is a bit smaller.
And so the interesting question is now what do we do if my data is larger?
And by the way what systems do if the data is larger differs?
So the easiest thing is you give an error message.
This is what for example, Oracle does, or at least does in the default, Oracle can handle
this, but by default you get an error message.
So if you just store something as large as a page, the system says, no, I cannot do this.
But sometimes the user absolutely wants to do this and he tells the database system that
he wants to do this.
For example, he wants to embed a document somewhere in the database system.
So something that is large.
And SQL has explicit support for this using two data types here, BLOP and CLOP.
So BLOP means binary large objects.
So this is basically like a file.
So this is a binary sequence, just as stored as it is.
And this can be large.
As you hear this, you can use for example to store an embedded document in your database
or versus you can store a movie.
Of course you should not do this.
So the system can handle large blobs, but if it's really large, you should not store
it as a blob, but store it in the file system.
So if you talk about multiple gigabytes, you don't want to do this as a blob.
But in principle you could.
So you can use a blob attribute and store very large data elements in there.
And crop is a character large object.
So like a block basically, also very large differences,
with a block it's really a byte range.
So the system does not interpret this at all.
It just stores it as it is.
With a clock range you say,
oh, this is a string, a very long string.
And then some systems support some,
at least some limited functionality.
You can look into the clock a bit.
Well, into the block usually cannot look at all.
Now while in the clock you sometimes can perform
some operations on them if you want to.
Okay, so what is the user asks for it?
If like you could have, for example, making a more realistic example here, we have a table
that's called user and then of course we have a name and this here might be for example,
we have a name that's 60 or so, then we have a mother fields and then at the end here we have
a photo and this we don't want to store as a string, yeah so therefore you say you have a blob.
of a blob field.
Now inside this photo attribute, you can now store a picture of your user if you want to.
Okay, this picture can be larger than a page, or larger than for example 16 kilobytes.
And now the system must be able to handle this.
Now note that in this use case here, this photo might be in the ballpark of a few hundred kilobytes.
I mean, it could be a few,
well, if you have a very high resolution,
it helps a few megabyte.
You probably do not want to store gigabytes,
although you can.
So if you declare a field as a blob,
you can store really large stuff in there.
But I'm just telling you beforehand,
systems are not optimized for storing really large blobs.
They support this,
but performance might not be optimal.
but definitely many kilobytes, megabytes,
this is definitely supportable props,
potentially up to gigabytes.
Okay, so nevertheless,
much of this is whatever we put there,
it's much larger than the page.
Now we need a way to cope this.
Now what we could naively do is the following.
So I take my, this is my page for my user.
Here's my user page.
So then I have here my user record,
And so initially here we have,
we have the name of course,
then some other stuff and so on.
So up to here.
Now comes, at some point here my photo starts
and the photo is so large that it doesn't fit on the page.
So what we could, what you don't want to do,
what we could do is of course the following.
So we take from my photo here,
I point to another record.
And this then again has photo, and actually I didn't draw it correct because it's not
done yet.
So the attribute continues and continues and continues, it also doesn't fit on a page.
So then we get another pointer here.
So we get a long chain.
So then we continue here with the photo and so on.
And so on.
We use as many pages as we need and we always point to the next page, to the next tab that
contains the next piece of data.
I mean we could implement it like this, but we don't want to implement it like this.
So this is not a good design.
I mean purely from a search perspective, of course it works because you just see my very
multiple pages, so this works, but this is very problematic for a number of reasons.
First, it means that if you access this attribute again, so if you touch it, then you can at
least potentially read an unbounded number of pages, because we don't know how large
my fold attribute is.
So because it could be very large, at least in theory, I've got some blob, has nearly
no space limit.
So if you want to reconstruct my tuple, I need to have an unbounded number of pages
And this is a nightmare for buffering.
It could be that your buffer manager doesn't have enough pages for example.
Or you get locking issues or all kinds of problems.
So you do not want to reach an unbounded number of pages.
If you know I read at most two pages or three pages, that's okay.
But if you say I have to read arbitrary many pages, and of course you need them because
Because your tuple is really split, meaning reading just this page is not enough, or this
and that page is not enough.
This is also not enough.
You must have all of them in memory at the same time to be able to process this photo.
That's very bad for buffering.
You don't want this.
I mean, in worst case, of course, your tuple, so your single attribute might be larger than
your memory.
Like if somebody has a blob attribute, stores a 4 GB blob, but you have only 2 GB memory,
the new problem.
So this is clearly problematic.
Other things that are very unpleasant is what happens if somebody doesn't update.
So you have a property and somebody doesn't update and the size changes.
If the size remains the same, I can just copy the data in, but if the size changes, so suddenly
I have to allocate new pages or release pages.
Very complicated.
So this is also not very attractive.
And also, I mean if you run a query now, how do you pass this, because after all, somebody
can query for this for the attribute, how you pass this through your query processing
is also very complicated.
Now, therefore, we don't want this.
What we do instead is we store the tuple and store the blob value separately.
So this is what most systems do.
Let's say here, this is my user now.
So this is my user tupper and the user of course has a name and so on.
And then we have all other attributes that we have.
And then we have, strictly speaking, just to be pedantic, of course the name is not written
like this.
I do it because it's easier to write.
Strictly speaking, we have only the fixed part of the name.
Here the variable part of the name comes at the end, just to write it correctly.
I also have a name variable part,
but I don't want to make it so complicated.
Okay, so I have my tuple here
and in my tuple somewhere there's my photo.
And this photo now points to somewhere else,
which has advantage that the user tuple itself
is reasonably small.
And for the block, we just store a pointer,
so add an ID basically.
So we could, for example, store a tuple ID
or something like this, which is more or less a pointer.
So tupple ID or pointer or something else, some mechanism.
And this points to the real blob.
And then during field processing,
we just pass along this tupple ID.
We don't do anything.
And only in the moment that we give it to the user,
so in the last possible moment,
somebody retrieves the photo,
then we retrieve the associated data,
load the photo in there,
or they give it to the user.
Or perhaps we don't even do this
because it depends on which API you use,
It could be that you really get the ID and then you have a special coil that says, okay,
I have this blob ID now, please give me the content of the blob and only in this moment
then it's retrieved. So the blob is stored really separately.
Good thing about the separation is that now the complexity of this large object is
hidden in only one place, namely the one that is responsible for storing and retrieving the
the blob, everybody else just passes the handle around.
So this is good.
Bad thing is, by design, you cannot do a lot with your blob.
You can pass it along, you can give it to the user.
But for example, in most systems, you cannot perform operations.
Like you cannot look at the content of the blob, at least not easily.
Same with clops.
Or perhaps with clops, they have some limited support, what you can do.
You can, for example, probably compare clops.
This is then implemented.
do this, then they must look at the real content of this elements, which is slower.
So blobs and clops are slower than regular variables because this data stored somewhere
else.
But at least the complexity of the immensely large values is removed from the tupper.
So the tupper itself now is again small, because the large part starts somewhere else.
Okay, so this design perspective makes sense.
And as I said, many systems do this, but this does not answer the question is, okay, I'm
What about here?
I said my blob is here and this can be now enlarged like megabytes.
Okay, how do I store this?
Because this has also listed somewhere and usually we assume everything is
stored in a page in database system.
So the page is the smallest unit we can have.
So we must somehow now map this megabyte range of data to pages.
We don't have to worry about this for during template processing,
you must do this mapping.
Okay, now here's a particular elegant way to implement this.
Namely, you take a large binary object, so your blob,
and then store it in a bee tree-like fashion like this.
Okay, now this needs some explanation.
So perhaps we start bottom up.
So we look at the leaf element, so this as the leaves.
So this contains the real data here.
So this is my real data.
And then here comes the first part of my blob, for example, the first 40,000 elements here,
40,000 and then comes the next 60,000 and each of them fit on a page.
If in this case, I assume I have 64 kilobyte pages.
Okay.
So then each of them fits.
This is the first page is not full completely.
There's some empty space for some reason,
but second next page is full.
And then comes T as the next,
then comes the next 50 K and then comes the next 60 K
and then comes the next 40 K for example.
And that's why I have split my,
so my total blob here has a size of total is
My total is 250K.
If you compute the sum here, this should be,
I believe it's right.
Yes.
So this is a sum here, 250.
250K is my blob on total.
And this is split over,
split over,
over five leaf pages.
Okay, so this is my storage here.
Now you could ask, was this any better than the chaining that we had mentioned before?
Yes, it is, because here in this case we don't do chaining, instead we index the content.
So here we do this in a B-tree like fashion.
Now you should realize of course that this is an illustrative sketch.
In reality if you have only 5 pages, you need only one B-tree node and this can happily
handle 5, it can handle thousands of pages, at least definitely more than 5.
Here we pretend as if you would need more inner nodes just because, you know, to make the picture
more meaningful. So, therefore on the inner nodes, we reference the leaf nodes and we reference them
by file offset. So like this page says, okay, everything in the file offset from 0 to 40,000
goes here and then everything between 40,000 and 100,000 goes here.
Okay.
So this is the index by offset.
Same in the root node here, the first 100,000 entries are here, the next 150,000 entries
are here.
Okay.
This should be intuitive because this indexing allows you to find an arbitrary position in
your blob in logarithmic time.
Because we can just search for more offset and then I find the page that contains it.
And I can also do a range queries like if you don't want to read the whole blob, but
just care for the header, for example, you can go to the beginning of the page where
can you read any sequence, any part of the data that you want, because we can just go
down in the B tree to whatever data range we need and then we get all the content.
This we can use to retrieve arbitrary parts of data.
Now if you look closely at this node here, you see that we do not just index the offsets,
but we index, so here we say index by, here we have written index by offset, but if we
are more precise, we say we don't index by offset, and that we do here is we index by
relative offset.
Now relative is important.
Now for the first inner node, it makes no difference because my relative offset here
is zero.
So this here is an implicit zero at the beginning, of course the zero is not stored here, but
this is an implicit offset of zero, therefore in the first page it makes no difference.
But in the second page, here we say, we see that this here, this third bucket here contains
the next 50,000 entries between as a position 100,000 and 150,000.
In the entry here, in the inner node on the right, this, let's give you the number, let's
call this here page 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So in the index in the page 2, we now say everything less than my own base offset plus
50,000 is here.
So here we write 50,000 and not, so we do not write here not 150,000, even though a traditional
B3 would do this.
So we don't do this, instead we say 50,000 plus this one.
So plus my previous separator.
So this is a plus basically.
You also see that the next boundary here is,
sorry, the next boundary here in the inner node,
we write 110,000, but of course the real value is 210,000.
Now, why do we do this?
So why do we use relative offset instead of absolute offsets?
Because this has a great advantage.
Assume for example, that we would hypothetically go here
And then we would delete, let's say 20,000.
So we say, here we say delete 20k.
So we want to remove 20k from my file.
So I cut a piece from a file.
So this, then here, what we would have to do is, we, of course, we clear this data because
it's gone.
So this is gone and then we update this value here from 100,000 to 80,000 and we update
this here from to 80,000 and you must also update this here to 230,000 and that's it.
That's it, the rest of the file we do not have to touch, in particular the right most
entry is, so this one here is the page 2, we do not have to touch.
is relative to my separator above me.
Yeah, so several to the 80,000.
Same for inserts.
So if you would, for example, insert here 20,
so if you would then insert 20k in here,
then my page is full.
So I insert 20k,
then I would update this here from 40 to 60,
I would update this here to 120,
and would update this to 120,
and this here to 270,
Yes, again, the right part is not affected.
So it means using this relative addressing,
we can insert and delete arbitrary ranges of data
in my blob.
And if you only have to touch a logarithmic number of entries,
this is a pretty cool feature.
So we can now manipulate very large data structures
without rewriting everything.
Because if you would have used absolute offsets
instead of relative offsets,
we would have to touch all this.
Now I just, you know, perhaps I can do this with a different color.
Yeah.
So if we would have done this, we would have updated this year to 70,000, this year to 130,
and so on.
So we would have updated everything, but we don't want to do this.
Yeah.
So we want that we don't have to touch all my data.
So by relative addressing, oh, by the way, of course, the number was wrong.
If I use absolute addressing, then of course,
I would not have to do an S70,
I would have to do 170, just to make it precise.
230 and then here we would have to do 270.
Okay, so, but we don't want to do this
because this means whenever we insert a delete,
we must rewrite all the offsets.
We don't want this, therefore we use relative offsets
and then we can only touch a logarithmic number of entries.
So this is a very nice and elegant way
to cope with large data.
It's very powerful.
Again, we can read everything.
We can update everything.
Only downside is perhaps if you're honest,
this is a very beautiful B2L-like structure
might be a bit over sophisticated.
So it's might be more powerful
than what your interface offers.
Because at least in SQL,
means it's not true for all database systems,
but at least in SQL,
you can only read and write a blob as it is.
Yes, you can rewrite a blob.
So you can delete a blob.
but you cannot grow a blob or shrink a blob,
at least not with simple statements.
Now, this is not true for all database systems.
Some database systems, for example,
are optimized for multimedia usage
and they support more powerful interfaces.
But if you have a simple SQL interface,
this using such a Btree thing here
might be too complicated.
No, it's very beautiful,
but nevertheless might be too complicated.
So if you have only a simple interface then you could perhaps live with something like
this.
And also we use an extent list.
So instead of having this ptree we just have one node here that contains, that describes
the elements here.
For example we say okay this is my block record here.
And then this says, okay, my blog consists of three pages starting at position 13.
So then comes here the data, data, data.
Then we say two pages starting at page 19, data, data, then the blog is done.
Now, so we just write it out.
And in the blog record itself, we have the number of pages and so the start positions,
number of pages and then the total length in bytes and also have a hash value.
Hash value is useful, so then we can speed up comparisons.
Okay, and now in worst case, of course, we could be that my extent list itself is so large that
it doesn't fit on a page, then we would have to resort to chaining.
Right, this is unlike this happens in particular, if you do our standard trick
of increasing the number of pages that we store and extend.
So if you here at some point don't store two pages, but we try to get larger
runs of pages. Remember when we talked about the allocation interface, we asked the data system,
okay, I need two pages or at least, at least one page, but I could have made use of five.
Then the system will give you more pages as it has space. And this we do here,
then we could, at some point we start asking for more pages. Okay. Then if you, if you do this,
then you can bounce the number of entries you do from your extent list. So then you don't have the
that we don't fit on a page.
Okay, so not as elegant.
Yeah, also the problem is now we can only manipulate
the blob in one piece so we can delete all pages.
So we can delete the blob or we can read the blob,
but we cannot easily, for example,
if you want to delete something in here in the middle,
it's not possible.
Maybe because I would have to touch all the other pages.
And also we cannot manipulate the blob easily.
On the other hand, if your query interface is so simple
then such an easier, so simpler,
block list extent list here is probably good enough.
Okay, so this is a simple alternative
to the sophisticated block tree.
Okay, so much for storing large record.
Now, if you look at how people use this,
you quickly realize that blocks are not always blocks
because when we say block,
Then we think like, so what when we say a blob, then we think perhaps a picture, a photo
sometimes.
Or when we think about a club, then we perhaps think like a document, so text, large text
document.
So if you want to have books, then you can install this as a club.
So this is what we think, however, this is what we think, but this is not necessarily
Okay, so why isn't it true?
Because users hate a particular feature of SQL.
Namely, we think about the example
that is in the beginning.
I said we have a user,
so let's do it in full SQL.
So we will create table,
create table,
user, then we give it, for example, a name,
And then perhaps we also give it, let's give it some other stuff here, like phone number
and so on, and many other attributes.
So an interesting question is, which data type do we give it?
So if you remember your introduction to databases, we probably told you, you should use for the
name something like, Varchar, yeah, and now what?
Let's for the moment, let's write here 20, but then we come back to this in a moment.
Okay.
So we write VARCHAR something.
So this is usually what we tell our students to use.
And users don't like this for a number of reasons.
First, just to, just to one step back.
If you use such a notation here, please do not, I write this in small print and I will
remove it in a moment.
Please do not use the data type char 20.
Don't do this.
In first approximation,
you should never ever use the data type character.
So character 20 looks like a string of length 20,
but has super odd behavior.
Don't use this data type,
except perhaps potentially for the single special case,
but even then you should think about this,
but there is one case where it might make sense.
could use character one.
If you want to store one letter, something,
character one might be okay.
But if you store more than one,
please don't use the character data type.
Character data type is a totally crazy data type
that makes no sense in modern life.
Now, so just to come back what this means,
character 20 is a string of length 20
that is space padded.
So if you insert a string that is shorter than 20,
the system pads it with spaces until the length of 20.
And at this point you can say, okay, a bit odd,
but why not?
But trust me, this is super odd behavior
as the moment you start to compare strings
of different lengths,
because then suddenly the system starts to patch
in unforeseen ways, don't do this.
Character data type is evil, don't use this.
It might have made sense
when people have used punch cards.
seen a punch card in a museum, you probably never saw one in your real life. At least I didn't ever
saw a punch card outside of a museum, I think. And I'm quite a bit older than you. So don't
don't use punch cards, don't use character. Okay, so use character varying, so variable length string.
So character varying 20, so this is how length and length that we could teach you,
So this is why we can use the user.
Problem is, what do we put here?
So why 20?
I said 20 is okay, but I would guess that even in the audience of this lecture, there is
somebody where 20 is not long enough.
I'm not absolutely sure, of course, but there are some people who have very long names,
surprisingly long names.
Yeah, in particular, if you come from other countries, some countries have the customs
that for example, you include your name of your mother and your father in your own name,
you inherit them, a combination of both.
And this invariably leads to the case of having pretty long names.
Yeah, so 20 is probably not good enough.
Okay, so then we say, okay, let's not use 20, let's use 40.
40 is probably good enough for most use cases.
But then again, you have some oddball user who has for some reason has a name that is
really, really long for whatever reasons.
And then you say, okay, you know what, to cope with this, I don't use 40, I use 200.
200 really is good enough for everybody.
And perhaps this is right.
I think 200 is probably indeed long enough for everybody.
How long do you make your phone number?
Yeah, okay.
You don't have to go to 200, but also phone numbers probably also vary and can be longer
than you might think.
Okay.
So, what happens is people enter very long numbers here to be sure that they never encounter
strings that is larger than what they need.
Looks good until you hit another problem.
Namely, what the systems require you is that the sum of all the Varchar lengths,
this here, unfortunately, must be less or equal to the page size.
Because otherwise we come back to the original problem.
By the way, this is also the reason why the system asks you for the length.
Because you could say, why does the system even have to know, just say I have a string
here.
So why does the database system want to know how long my string can be?
And the answer is, for multiple reasons.
First it wants to make sure that your string fits on a page, and it can do this if it can
So if you look at the maximum length of each strings,
you can check if the sum of all maximum length
plus the other, plus of course,
yeah, plus other attributes, of course,
not only VATCH, plus other attributes,
plus other attributes must fit on a page.
And if you make all your string fields very long,
so if you give them very long upper bounds,
then the sum of all the upper bounds
might be beyond the page size,
and then the system will complain.
Like as I mentioned before, if you do this in Oracle, Oracle says, I cannot do this.
Please you have to make sure that your tupper fits on the page.
And you get an error message.
And other systems are a bit more generous for in declaration, but nevertheless, they
have to squeeze the tupper on the page somehow.
Also some people use this information for index management, for example.
So they want to know how long your data is.
And if you put there very long upper bounds, then
Yes, this doesn't work. Okay, so declaring your voucher attributes unpleasant
Either it's too short very bad and you can enter cannot insert the data or if it's too long and then
We get error messages from the system
as therefore people hate this and then came for some
Brilliant people came up with of course is not so really brilliant by the way
Don't do this at home, but nevertheless, I just mentioned it.
What some people do is and say, hey, you know what?
Forget all these length restrictions.
I just declare my name here as clop.
Oh, sorry, this is do we know?
So I declare everything here, I declare my name as clop, character large objects.
And now I can have a name that is in multiple megabytes.
So no problems, this length here is good enough.
And of course this name, you could say this is ridiculous.
But if you look at other examples, for example, URL, then this is indeed the thing, because
most URLs are short, but you know, the long tail of URL length is very, very long.
So there are some URLs that are very long.
And then people say, you know what, I just use a CLOP.
And this works, of course.
So because, remember the mechanism we just looked at in the lecture, this works.
We now have a mechanism that can store multiple megabytes,
but this has terrible performance
terrible performance
because the moment you start
operating on your club
you must look up this long string and then do something about this
by the way some really
I once heard this in a talk
by some Microsoft people
they said they had to support the following
which is really insane by the way
but they do support this
you say a name club
and then you say primary key
this is really if you think about what's happening here
key this is if you think about the implementation of what's going on now you you've now built an
index on on a um on a very long object that is stored separately using another lookup data
structure this is all super super expensive you know i mean this works but works super expensive
and this is this is not good yeah we don't want this and i mean of course this is the real reason
happened is because users don't like to specify string lengths and they want to have the flexibility
of having long strings. And of course people realize that this is a problem and therefore
they say, you know, the solution is differently. Namely, we give the user a mechanism that
unfortunately is not standardized. This is bad, unfortunately. Each system does it differently.
But for example, Postgres calls this data type that you can use and you probably should use
and also URL text.
Now, what's happened is, if the system encounters text or if it doesn't encounter text but it's
smart and so encounters CLOP, you could do the same with CLOP.
The user has declared the name as CLOP, just be on the safe side.
But in reality, most names are short.
well you could have an oddball user that has a kilobyte name but most users will have a name
that is 20 characters or less now so they are not clops they're short same with text so text is a
mechanism that tells you user i want to test the system i want to store a very length strings i
don't know how long it will be most of the time the string will be short but if it's if it's long
Please make it happen.
So the system will do it.
It will optimize for the short case.
And if the text here is long and ready, and of course it sees it, then it maps it silently
without telling you to a clop.
So the text is stored out of the out of the end.
So outside the page, if it's long, if the text is short, then stored inside the page.
By the way, Postgres calls this here toast.
Toast, this is not the standard name, so Posca's uses.
I actually forgot what Toast stands for.
Toast at the beginning says, totally automatic, but I just want to look it up to give you
the correct acronym.
Toast, yeah, yeah.
I don't know, I must correct myself.
So the name that Posca's uses, Toast is the Oversized Attribute Storage Technique.
So this means that if your text is short, then it's stored nicely in the tuple as usual.
And if the text is long, then it is stored somewhere else, like what we saw on the previous
slides.
Okay, and such a mechanism makes sense.
You should absolutely do this.
Because as we write here, users misuse props and clops.
They use a clop to avoid specifying a maximum length because they hate maximum lengths.
But nevertheless, these clops are not really large objects.
but they're not really large.
And so we have to handle them.
On the other hand, we cannot know this for sure.
I mean, for a name, probably yes, it's relatively short.
But if the field is not called name,
but it's called like photo or even worse movie,
okay, probably nobody would be so crazy
to then store the movies in database, hopefully.
But you never know, movie file.
So if you declare this as a blob,
then this will be indeed large.
We cannot know beforehand.
Now we only see when the user has done it.
And therefore what your system should do is,
it should implement this whole mechanism here anyway,
by the way, and clop and clop,
and I will count text as the same.
Text is basically a declaration of a string
that silently maps to clop.
That's what text is there.
So text is a better string if your system supports it.
Unfortunately not standardized,
but if your system supports it,
text is probably what you want to use.
Now what the system should do is, it should optimize for the common case of being short.
And we can use the following three steps here.
If my blob is really, really short, for example, my blob is shorter than a tuple ID, then we
adjust the text in the tuple ID.
So remember that we store a blob.
So original picture said, this is my tuple.
Then here comes my blob field somewhere.
And this is a relative, it's a tuple ID.
And this points to somewhere else.
Okay.
This is one way to implement this.
Now if my string is short, so for example, if it's less than eight characters, I just
put the string here.
Just put it in here.
Now if it's larger than it, then it don't cost me anything.
If my string is larger than a tuple ID but smaller than a page, then I take a page and
then I store my blob here.
And only if, so this is case 1, case 1, squeeze it in.
Case 2, put it on a separate page but just point here.
And only case 3 is really large, so then we do the full blown mechanism, then we have
for example a tree or some other mechanism.
But this will be rare.
one or two.
And by the way, there are even some mixed forms mentioned possible.
For example, this is what Postgres does.
If you declare a string as a text, then it will first store like a regular string.
So like this here, so like we have fixed size and then comes my string field here, even
for longer strings.
So this put it at the end.
And only if this part here goes beyond a page,
then we put in the tablid here,
and then point somewhere else.
Okay?
If it's short, we put it in the page,
if it's long, put it on a separate page.
So different ways to implement this,
but you definitely want to optimize for short blobs
and clops, because in reality,
most clops and blobs are short.
But upper size, unfortunately, is very large.
So we need a full mechanism,
But we optimize for the short version.
Okay, so this much for tuple storage.
So after this slide, you hopefully hope, know how to store tuples.
Yeah, so if you have many attributes and fixed size, variable size, how to do this, what
to do with compression if you want to do this and what to do with long attributes.
So this is what we covered.
But now what we would want to look up next are index structures.
Because what we can do so far in the lectures only, so we have a familiar relation here
is map to a segment, so I have a segment, draw it like this, I have a segment, and then
in the segment I have a page, then I have another page and so on.
So this is my own whole storage so far, page n.
And if I want to read something, if I do a select star from R,
where x equals 7, then the only thing, option I have so far is I read the first page,
look at all the tablets, check the condition.
If it's true somewhere, I output it, read the next page and so on.
So this means my query time here is linear
as a database size.
That's what we call a full table scan.
We read everything, full table scan.
And of course, full table scan,
read all the pages in my relation,
look at all the tuples in my pages,
check the condition if it's true,
I'll put it to the user, full table scan.
This works, but it's not so super attractive
In particular, there is one case where we frequently have to check if the table exists
and these are primary keys.
So if somebody says I have an attribute and I declare x integer primary key, then I must
make sure that no other x value exists.
So I must check my income X against all existing values.
And for this, full table scan is not really an option.
I mean, I know a few specialized database systems that do check primary keys with full
table scans, but these are really specialized systems that are pretty sure that they will
have a low number of inserts.
Because what happens, I mean, just do the math, for the first tuple, it's okay, no other
tuple exist.
For the second tuple, I have to check against one other tuple.
For the third tuple, I have to check against two previous tuples and so on.
So which means for the nth insert, it compares with n-1 tuple, so all previous n tuples
And this clearly has a very bad asymptotic here,
because if you think about the number of comparisons
that you perform, this means that we perform
a half
n times n-1 comparisons.
This is the O of n squared.
table scans are not an option for primary keys in practice.
Yeah, because if my n here, just think about what happens.
If my n is 10, that's okay.
But if my n is a million here,
and as we do 1 million square comparisons,
this is not a good number.
So you cannot insert 1 million elements
and do a full table scans for each primary key.
Now this is just not feasible.
Okay, so for primary keys,
we need a way to find a tuple quickly.
And in general, not only for primary keys,
for all kinds of selective queries.
give me a student with my trigonome number of 1, 2, 3.
So then we have to do this quickly, we don't want to look at all the students.
And for this we use index structures.
Now we can use index structures in two ways basically.
So the first case here is a so called point query, for example x equals 7, so this is
just what I said.
Or another point query would be to say, because it can be a compound, it doesn't have to be
So say a equals 5 and b equals 10.
So this is also a point query because we take my attributes and say this has to be have
a z value.
So this is a point access.
Second kind of query here is a range query where we say for example x between 10 and 20
Or you could say another kind of range queries, x less or equal to 20 or something like this.
So this is now half open interval.
So there are different kinds.
So the second category here are range queries because they have not the specific values
that we are looking for, but a range of possible values.
The second category here is point access.
We know the value, we just want to find the attributes that have this particular value.
Okay, and these are typically the two kinds of queries that we support with index structures.
Now there exist some index structures that can do more complicated, complex predicates
and we will talk briefly about some also in the lecture, but this is more rare.
So the bread and butter point of queries that we want to support is a point query and the
range query.
And of course a primary key lookup corresponds to a point query, because you must check,
does this particular primary key already exist in my database system?
If yes, you must output an error message.
searching for one specific value,
and we have to find the value quickly.
And ideally, not only, ideally,
necessarily in sub-linear runtime.
So we want to be faster than full-tabit scan.
And so we want to retrieve this quickly.
Now, the most commonly used data structure
to do this is of course a B-tree.
And I'm pretty confident that all of you
have looked already at B-trees
in the introduction to the databases,
such an important data structure.
And really everybody uses this.
This is the dominant data structure.
In fact, not only database systems use it,
file systems, everybody.
Everybody who has to store persistent data,
B-trees are extremely, extremely popular.
They're not the only data structures,
they're also alternatives that we could use for some cases,
but B-trees are very, very popular.
They are the most widely used data structures
for external memory, for good reasons by the way.
Yeah, so these have many good properties.
And also note that here we write here B-trees and variants
because very few people implement it as a classical B-tree
because people realize that it's better
to implement some variants of this
and we come to this in a moment.
But nevertheless, so these are all variations
of the same theme.
So they are all multi-way index structures
with these properties we see here.
So the classical definition says,
a B tree has a degree of K.
And now my conditions are each node except the root
has at least K entries.
Each node has at most two K entries.
Another way to formulate this is,
so instead of having explicit degree K,
we say this here corresponds to each node,
each node is at least half full.
So this is what we want here, not the root, but everybody else is at least half full.
This is the first condition.
Second condition, all, so this is basically one here.
Second condition is all leaf nodes are the same depths.
and interestingly if you have these two properties at least half full and
everybody's the same depth what happens is you can bounce the depth of the tree
because you know that my my the depth of the tree depth of the tree I'm sorry for
my handwriting is not as not perfect even without an drawing tablet that I
use here and with drawing tablet it's even worse okay so the depth of the tree
is now less or equal to the logarithm of the number of entries to the to the
depth to the base k. Okay, so this is what we get here. So we are at most logarithmic
in the, and of course, the fun thing is that k here tends to be large, like k can be, for example,
they are depends a bit on your data types and so not so easy to say, but
I'm not sure, not say approximately, let's say, for example,
Okay because it depends on what you store but can be for example a thousand
This means your tree is
Logarithmic to to depth thousands is very very shallow because if we have you have 1000 entries. I need only
one node if I have a million entries so I
I
Can say my tree has steps to if I have a billion entries
three and that means that for all practical purposes p trees have a depth of less or equal
to four most likely now probably only three three at most four this will be the depth of a b tree
so if you compare this to a to a traditional data structure like i mean what you learned in your
direction to uh algorithms data structures is probably something like a red black tree
yeah don't use this well yeah that's not true there are some corner cases where you want to do
But let's say for definitely not for databases and probably not even for most other.
I mean, they have some good properties, but in first approximation, you don't want to
use red-black trees, even though they are logarithmic, of course.
So, lookup in a red-black tree is in O of log n and lookup in a B tree is also in O of log n.
So, why do I say red-black trees are bad and B trees are good?
The problem is that we hide all the constants here.
So we see the depth of a B-tree here is, the depth is log k of n.
And this is for example, log 1000 of n.
And then this is typically 2 to at most 4.
So this is a, let's make perhaps a more concrete example.
Let's assume, not typically, let's assume we insert 1 million entries here, 1 million
entries, the depths of this year will be 2.
For 1 million entries, I need 2 levels.
Because if each leaf node contains at least 1000 entries, which means I have at most 1000
leaf nodes.
can hold this because my node can hold between 1000 and 2000 elements if
my case 1000. So I need two levels of my tree for
one million entries. While if you look at the depth of the red black tree here,
the depth of the red black tree, let's do the separatists, the depth of the
So the right black tree is, as you hopefully all know, log 2 to the base n, and in fact
it is even worse, it is 2 times log 2 to the base n, in the worst case.
So this does not have to be the case, but let's make the depth more precise.
In worst case, it is 2 to the log n and in best case, it is log 2 to the base n.
Best case is log 2 to the base n, worst case is 2 times log 2 to the base n.
This is of course all logarithmic in the complexity, but in absolute numbers, so if
If you say this means 1 million entries, we'll have a depth here between 20 and 40.
And this is pretty deep.
I mean, going 20 steps in a tree or even worse, 40 steps in a tree is very different from going two steps in a tree.
Okay, now to be, I mean, this is all hand-waving.
a step in a red-black tree is cheaper than a step in a B tree.
So therefore you cannot compare this number directly.
But trust me, the lookup in a B tree
will be much faster than the lookup in a red-black tree in practice.
So B trees are nearly always preferable over red-black trees.
There are a few special circumstances that are not true,
but in first approximation, you prefer a B tree over a red-black tree.
And you definitely prefer a few stores on an external medium.
So even in memory, P3s are usually better,
but on an external medium, they are always better.
Because if you would do this on an external medium,
and we would do here 20 or 40 seeks on a disk,
remember a seek cost me something like three
or four milliseconds, you would die.
Yeah, so we would spend 80 milliseconds for a lookup,
absolute disaster.
But if we do this in a P3 here,
then we spend perhaps eight milliseconds,
if you can perhaps spend 8 milliseconds.
Now, so in particular, since the root of the B-tree
will virtually always be in your buffer manager,
so you have only one page fault.
And if you have depth two,
you will have only one page fault,
cause the root will be cached.
So leaf node might not be, so they have one page fault.
So this, while the red black tree,
this would be a terrible performance.
Okay, so B-trees are good.
Of course, you can always make things better
and we will see, look at ways to improve B-trees.
but B-trees have very nice properties. They are shallow trees, so not very deep,
and they guarantee me logarithmic lookup. And another plus part, by the way, they are reasonably
easy to implement. So if you wake me up in the middle of the night, I'm able to implement a B-tree
for you, at least a B-plus tree I can implement by heart, so I don't have to look at any book,
I can implement this for you. I would not be able to implement a red-black tree without looking at
The same is true for you.
I don't know if you have ever implemented a black tree.
So you have this balancing criterion like how many reds and how many blacks can follow
each other.
This you might perhaps remember, but probably you already get this balancing criterion wrong.
And then the second thing is if you violate it, you have to start with tree rotation.
And I think it unlikely that you can put the correct tree rotation next to the correct
balancing criterion without looking it up somewhere. So red and black trees are very complicated.
B-trees are pretty elegant structure, which means you can implement it by heart. So you don't have
to look it up, at least if you look at B-plus trees. Now for just for at least once here, we
look at the real B-tree that you all hopefully remember from your introduction to databases.
This looks like this.
So here we have my keys and my values.
So this is the keys that we store.
So this here is a key.
And the value will always be,
so this here is a tuple ID.
Because remember we use an index to find a tuple,
which means if an index attribute likes a primary key
or whatever we have, so if a key attribute
or the name, which doesn't have to be real key.
And then the, we associate this key value
So if you want to find the other attributes, so if, for example, somebody says, select
name from students where
id equals 16, what happens is we start, and this we assume this is now a search tree for this id.
So we start here in the root, we see I am searching for 16, 16 is less than 47, therefore
I go to my left subtree, then we go here, I look at the next node, I say 16 is less
than 22, so I follow this edge, then I go to this node and then I look at the elements
here and see oh here is 16, then I find it.
Now somebody, the query didn't ask me for the tabular ID but asked me for the name, therefore
what I do is I take this table ID and I follow it to the page.
Follow to the page and then here I will find my student and this now will have the name
and everything.
So this is how an index lookup works.
And we use this value here to separate the space.
Here we see the value 47 is stored here.
Everything less than 47 is here.
Everything larger than 47 is here.
this node here. Here we have an anti-88. Everything larger than 88 is in this subtree. Everything
between 88 and the previous value, namely 67, everything between 88 and 67 is here.
So let's put correct boundaries here. This here is larger than 88.
This here is larger than 67 and less than 88. This is here and so on.
So here this is everything less than 67.
So this is how the separation works.
Now the values here splits this,
and this has many nice properties.
Okay, now I mentioned already before,
most people don't implement the classical B tree,
but they implement a B plus tree,
which as a first glance looks like just a small change.
Looks very similar to what we saw before,
But in reality, B plus trees are so much better than B trees.
In particular, they are so much easier to implement.
They also have other properties, other advantages.
But main, if you ask me, the main advantage of a B plus tree is that it is super easy
to implement while a B tree is not so super easy.
There are some complicated things that can happen.
Okay, so now how does a B plus tree work?
First glance, it looks just like a B tree.
The difference is the key value pairs are only in the leaf nodes.
So here we see the value 2 and the table ID, so this is one entry, one entry, one entry,
these are only in the leaf nodes.
And the inner pages only contain the separator values.
So the key table ID pairs are only here.
So here we say everything less than 49 is in this left subtree.
This looks like before, but note that the value that we had before, namely here we had
which was stored in itself.
So previously my root entry contained 47 at top most entry.
And it was in the node.
Now, oh, sorry, wrong direction.
Now my 47 sits here in a leaf page, instead on the inner page, as I have some separate
the value that does not have to be in the, in the values.
So here we say everything up to 49 is here in my left part, everything larger than 49
is on my right part.
go here, then everything larger than 37 is here and then and so on.
So the inner values contain separators that might or might not occur in the data.
Also note that now I write the balancing conditions here, everything up to 49 and note that this
here is less or equal.
Well, in the previous example, I have deleted it already, previously I said, here I said
everything less than 47 is here.
Here I say less or equal to 49 is here.
So this is small but important difference.
Less or equal to 49 is here, larger than 49 is here.
Now see here, less or equal to 25 is here, above 25, 25 and less or equal to 35 is here,
above 35 is here and so on.
And you see the 25, it does occur here in this, here the 25 does occur, while the 49
does not occur.
value we have is 47. So the inner node can contain values that do not occur in the data.
Okay, now why do we prefer B plus 3 over B3? In the first glance, I have to store the value twice.
So if you look at the 45, I store it both here and here. So isn't it bad to mean storing
everything twice? It doesn't sound so attractive. Yeah, but the advantages, there are two advantages.
First, the inner node now only contains the key value
and not the table ID value.
So only the key, we save the space for the table ID,
which means that my entries on the inner nodes are smaller.
And this means I can fit more entries on the page.
And this means my fanout is higher.
And higher fanout is a super great thing
because remember our formula set,
my depth here is log k.
And if my elements are smaller, my k is higher.
And of course my k is as much as I can fit on a half a page.
If my elements are smaller, I have a higher fanout and therefore my tree will be less
deep and therefore lookup will be faster.
So this is the one advantage of the b-tree, a b-plus tree, higher fanout.
Second advantage, if you ask me, this is relatively even more important, namely it's
In a B tree, pretty nasty things can happen.
For example, assume here we would, look at this example here, we would want to delete
the value, let's say 37, sorry, they want to delete the value 43.
Then my page would be less than half full because I have only one element here.
So now what we would have to do is we would have to text the next element in this case
47 and move it here and then but then we need a new element for the root and then we could
for example pull up the 55 here and you know this is super super complicated to implement
because now suddenly we must touch quite a few pages just because we want deleted one
element also because we must update the separator and separate it must move down super difficult
operations while in a in a b plus tree we don't have mean in the b plus three we don't have to
move a value there's a 47 if you want to do something because what is that you must physically
move it in a b plus tree we can just store value in the um in the node that does not necessarily
have to occur yeah like uh for example if somebody inserts a 48 i just inserted here do nothing
Also if somebody deletes 25, we delete 25, we do nothing.
The separator says everything up to 25 is here, it's true, there is no 25 but this doesn't
matter.
So this is still true.
While in a B tree we could not do this so easily.
So B plus tree we can do most operations, I say most not all, but we can do most operations
on the leaf nodes and we much more rarely have to touch the inner nodes.
Basically a B tree, we would have to update the internodes much more frequently.
Therefore, don't use B trees, use B plus trees.
They are both faster and much easier to implement.
So B plus trees are what we usually want to do.
And so now how does this, if you zoom into the, I mean this is just a picture, how does
this physically look like?
So the inner node probably looks something like this.
So we have, so this is a page of an inner node.
We start with a log sequence number as usual.
So this is for recovery, just the last change on this page.
This is just a number.
So then we store the so-called upper pointer here.
So remember that we have one page.
So we have a lot of, let's say, look at this example here.
So we have a lot of key pointer pairs.
Here so, or perhaps I should say pointer key pairs, because I say this page, so this, let's
give it a number, this page seven is responsible for everything up to 58.
Then this page 20 here is responsible for everything for up to 90.
So we have pairs of page number key, page number key, page number keys.
We have many of these and we have one page more.
And this is what we call here.
This is what we call upper in this slide.
Because this is everything that is larger than the largest key in a page.
The same here, my largest key is 49.
Everything larger than 49 comes to this upper pointer.
Okay.
As we see in this page structure here, the upper is a page of the rightmost child.
So because this rightmost child is different.
And then we store how many entries do we have.
And then we have of course many key child pairs.
So key child, key, it's more precisely key child page.
Now this is the page number of the child page.
Also key child, key child, key child.
This is inner node.
On the leaf node, in principle we do the same, let's ignore this thing here for a moment.
We also have the, sorry, I didn't see this, let's ignore this for a moment, we come to
this back.
So we start the same, we have a log sequence number, then we have the number of elements
that we want to store, then we have key tablid pairs, this is not a child page of course,
but this is now tablid, so we have many key tablid pairs.
two entries more that I didn't explain yet.
First one we see is this next pointer here.
So why do we have this?
So you saw this also in this picture,
in the B plus three, when we look at the,
this is a leaf page, let's call this leaf page one.
This is leaf page two.
And then the leaf page one has a pointer here
to the leaf page two.
This is here the next pointer.
This is what I mark here and we have right to it next.
Same here, we have a next pointer.
Here we have a next pointer.
And I see we always store the next leaf page.
Next.
Okay, why do we need this?
Strictly speaking, we do not need it in a strong sense, but it's very useful to have
because it allows us to run queries more quickly.
Now, for example, if somebody wants to run a query, I want to say x between, let's say
27 and 54, what happens is I go into my, I search for 27 in my B3.
So I go, say 27 is less than 49, I go down here.
27 is between 25 and 35, so I go here.
So then on the page, because on the page the elements are sorted too, so I store them sorted
on the page.
Therefore I find the first element that I have to retrieve is 29, because this is between
27 and 59.
So 29 I found as first element, and then I just go to the right.
That's the 29 qualifies, 35 qualifies.
Then I reach the end of the page, I follow the next pointer, I read.
Yeah, 36 qualifies, 41 qualifies, 43, 47.
I follow the next pointer, I go to the next page.
53 qualifies and then here I count the first image that does not qualify and then I can't stop
Because I know everything further to the right will be larger
Therefore I can now stop processing
okay, and so I
Use this next pointer here to simplify my search
So basically I only navigate down the tree once in the beginning and then I run to the right on the page
and when I hit the end of the page, I follow the next pointer.
This gives me pretty good performance when running a range query.
Okay, so this is what we need to use the next pointer for.
Now what about this ominous number here?
So I said here, it writes this here as tilde 0, and this means, this means 1, 1, 1, 1,
and so on, 1 in binary.
So this is a value that just contains the 1.
or another notation here would be of course just write minus one.
Now, why do we use this?
Yeah, the problem is when we navigate down the tree, how do we know when, because in the picture
here I said we start with the leaf node, we start with the root node here and then I go down for
example to this node and then at this point I have found a leaf node and then I can start
retrieving the values. How do I know that I found a leaf node?
Yes, this is an inner node, this is an inner node, and this is a leaf node.
But how do I know this? Because in the data system, I just say here, this might
be here page number, this something, then I say this here is page number 120, this is
page number 40, how should I know that page number 40 is the leaf node while page number
120 is an inner node?
I don't know this, at least not in advance.
So I just know that my next level is on page 120, if it's a leaf or an inner node, I don't
know.
And one way to tackle this problem is to distinguish them.
So basically I write in the header of the page a value that cannot occur in the inner
node.
Like here for example, on the leaf node,
we write this value here,
and this value, because this is minus one,
this cannot be the page number of the rightmost child.
And that's why at least I must make sure
that this cannot be the case.
So this here is the same memory location at this one here.
And so when I fetch the page,
I look at this field, the second field,
I check if the second field on my page is minus one.
If yes, I encountered a leaf node, if not, I encountered an inner node.
Okay, and of course in my inner nodes, then I process differently than if I encounter
a leaf node.
So leaf nodes, of course, I do the lookup differently.
And so some mechanism like this you need.
Now there are different ways to implement this, but you have to realize, I mean, this
is surprisingly difficult because you are not the only one who navigates the data structure.
Like you start from the root and then you move down, but while you move down, somebody
else might change the tree.
In particular, it could be that the depth of the tree grows.
So your tree might become deeper and somebody might split nodes.
And therefore it's not so totally obvious, at least in advance, it's not totally obvious
if my next page is a leaf node or an inner node.
So you have to have some kind of mechanism to handle this.
use a marker that we did here.
An alternative technique would be to use counting.
So if you remember how deep your tree is,
then you can count on which level you are.
And of course, if somebody splits,
so that when you grow the trees,
the depths can increase,
but you can know,
I think we will see this,
and then we come to the insert logic,
you can know that you only grow at the root,
therefore the depths of a node relative to the leaves.
So if you say, this is,
you must not count from the root,
you must count from the leaves.
depth one, depth two.
If you count like this,
you can be sure that your depths of an individual tree,
of an original node will not change.
And therefore you can use this also to recognize
if you have a leaf on inner node.
And so you can use some mechanism to handle this,
but you need to be aware of this.
Distinguishing inner nodes from leaf nodes
is not as easy as you might wish.
And this is of course the danger of doing what we do here,
because here we draw a small,
me and draw your picture say hey obviously this is a leaf node but if you implement it yourself
and i think you will do this in the exercises i hope you do this in the exercises if you implement
it yourself you will realize it's not so totally obvious and if you if in your lookup you are now
at an inner node or at leaf node okay and now so this is a high level operation now how do we
how do you perform a lookup?
So when we search an element in my B-tree
and we do with the following,
first we start with the root node.
So this is my current node.
So then we say, is my current load in leaf node?
If yes, then we return the current page
or if somebody really wanted to find the entries
and we returned the entry on the page.
So then we look at the entries on the page
and we return the entry.
Now, if it's not a leaf node,
node, then we find the first entry in my inner node that is greater or equal to the search
key and we do this of course with the binary search.
And now this is important to do because, I mean, my picture here looks small, like if
you say, first for the value 28, you would say, I just look at the two elements and then
find it.
But in reality, this here can be thousand or multiple thousand perhaps, yeah, a thousand,
2000, and then you don't want to look at all the entries.
Yeah.
If you want to compare your search key with thousands entries on a page, this is slow.
You don't want to do this.
What we do instead is we keep all entries sorted, then we can do binary search.
So we jump to the middle and then always come, always come, jump to the smaller page.
Okay.
And so until we find the first entry that is greater or equal to the search key, and if
If we do not find such an entry, then we follow the upper edge.
So which means, because if you don't find this, it means my search key is larger than
every entry that we have.
If this is the case, then we go to the rightmost child.
So we follow the upper entry.
Otherwise we go down to the corresponding page to my, to my value here.
So if we come to this, look at this picture here, let's hypothetically say I'm searching
let's say 48.
So then I start here.
This is an inner node.
I check what is the first entry that is greater or equal to 48.
This is 49.
I follow this pointer.
Then here, another inner node.
What is the first value that is greater equal to 48?
There is no such value.
Therefore I follow the uppermost pointer.
Then I'm here.
Then here I would say,
or let's say I search for 47.
That's nicer.
Let's say 47.
Then I come to the leaf node.
Of course, I do the same.
Find the first element that is greater or equal to 47.
In this case, it is 47.
So we have found the place.
And also on the leaf node,
we do this with binary search
because of the same argument,
namely that we can have thousands of elements
and then we don't want to look at all of them.
So this is how the basic lookup works.
So, and, oh, looking at my time, I have only 10 minutes left.
Yeah, so, but then before doing first operation on the B tree, perhaps one of the inserts
we can cover because it's pretty simple too.
So, but first continuous lookup.
So, so once you found the correct pointer to follow, of course, then we continue here,
then we check again.
I do have a, in a note, if yes, do this again, if you leave note, we search for this.
Okay.
how basic lookup works.
Now, interesting question is,
can you do better than this?
And answer is yes, at least sometimes.
Meaning it's not always possible,
depends on your data, what you have,
but you can do this a bit better than perhaps.
Because what we said so far is,
we go to a page, then we do binary search.
Yeah, so,
so, I mean, my pages are too small
And because I go here and then I have a thousand elements and do the binary search
Of course, if you have a thousand elements then you will do this binary search roughly
Look at ten elements on your page
Question is can you look at less than ten elements in a page in particular?
You know that you look at this ten element page ten elements at random
Which means that you will most likely or at least often you will get cache misses and also your branch predictor will be unhappy about you
because you realize the mean binary search works like this.
Let's draw a picture here.
So if this is my 1000 elements that I have.
So binary search like this, I jump in the middle
and then if, then I compare,
and then if it's less, then afterwards I jump here.
If it's more, then I jump here.
Okay.
Okay, now if you search values at random,
if you always search for the same values, okay,
but if you search for values at random,
then the probability that you go jump
to the left and the right is roughly 50%.
Yeah, and this is bad,
because this means that your CPU cannot predict reliable
if you go to the left position
or if you go to the right position.
And this will make your CPU a bit unhappy.
And this will unfortunately mean
that you will get suboptimal performance.
And also because, I mean if you think about classical binary search implementation like
this here, so we have a lower and upper bound, upper bound and we have of course the value
x.
And so the classical implementation looks like this.
So while lower is not upper, then we say middle is equal to lower plus upper minus lower half.
So this is my middle here.
if data at position M is less than X,
then we say upper bound is equal to M,
else if data M is less than X,
is larger than X, then lower bound is M plus one,
else return M.
Oops.
And also do some other way to real single.
Okay, so this is a classical way
to implement a binary search.
Now good news is you only do this logarithmic number of times.
So if you have those elements,
if you do this only 10 times,
This is not so super cheap.
Particularly because the CPU cannot predict reliably
if this ifs here will be true or false.
So this could be true or false at 50% chance,
because if you jump through this,
then you sometimes will be true,
sometimes it will be false.
And this is bad for your performance,
because if you want to predict what you want to take,
because you all have,
or most likely you all have,
you have CPUs with order of order execution.
And therefore the CPU runs multiple instructions in parallel
and it can only do this if it can predict what you are doing.
So can we speed this up?
Yes, there are two ways to speed this up.
And by the way, just as I see this code,
know that you should not do the following.
So I wrote this here so they can remove it later.
Do not do this here.
Don't do this.
You could think, hey, isn't this the same?
Is it easier to write?
you can get overflows.
So if L and R are up and low about a large,
you get numerical overflows.
Don't do this.
Dangerous, but lose you right like this.
So the question is, can we do better?
And answer is yes.
In two ways.
First, we can make this here branch free.
So we can make it so that the,
this, we don't have an if in the inner lobe.
without if.
Okay, and you could say, how can we ever do this?
Although I'm not sure that really explains this.
Might go beyond, why not?
Oh, let's do this.
Okay, so you now see some a bit more advanced computation here.
So how do we do this?
We say, we start with the same upper and lower bound.
Let's say N is upper minus lower.
So then while,
while
n is larger than one,
so if more than one element,
we say
n is equal to L plus
n,
or let's, let's, let's,
no, let's, let's formulate it like this.
m is equal to
n half
okay and now what happens is
and of course
and we always shrink it
so at the end of the loop we say
n is equal to
n
divided by 2
so my bound is always half
the only question is do we have to go to the left half
or to the right half
basically what we would have to do
I first write it with an if but then I replace it with an if
So basically what we would do is, if data L plus M is larger than X, then we say L is
equal to L plus M.
And so if you have to go to the right half,
then we must increase my lower bound.
If we go to the left half,
then we don't do anything with the lower bound.
Okay, so at this point we have only one if,
and the really funny thing is
we can really remove this if two.
Yeah, because what we can do is,
one way for example to implement,
there might be a way to implement this,
one way to implement this is,
We say L is increased by M times data, data L plus M larger than X.
Okay?
Now what happens here?
So here we compare this value.
If this is larger than this value here is one.
If it is less, it's less or equal than it's zero.
We multiply m with one or two, so if it's larger than we have m, if it's less than we
have zero, we increase a by this and then that's it.
So now this new loop contains no if.
So of course we do a multiplication, in fact this you might wish to use other ways to, you
might want to turn this here into a CMOF, conditional move, but I don't want to go into
assembler at this point here.
So I'm just saying, so you can, then it will be even faster.
even faster, but I don't want to make it too complicated.
Just saying this, if you formulate it like this, you can do a binary search that does
not have an if, and in insight.
Yeah, and this means therefore, of course, that the if cannot be mispredicted.
So this will be faster, at least if the, I mean, I did extensive performance test of
this, this will be faster if the range that you're searching for is not too large.
If it is very large, then it is faster to do the multiple ifs instead of using conditional
moves, so instead of using branch free binary search.
But just so this is a branch free binary search.
For small ranges and small means a few thousand or perhaps a few 10,000, this here is faster.
And typically a B3 page is in this ballpark.
So branch free binary search is a good idea.
Now question is, can we, so this will be a bit faster than the other binary search.
The question is, can we do even better?
And the answer is yes, yes, we can.
At least, I mean, so this branch of binary search you can always do.
The next trick I want to show you, you can only do sometimes.
And this is because this depends on the data types that we have.
So if you have strings, then we cannot do much.
But what if we have numbers, for example?
Yeah, so assume, so here we are, and we are, we want to search, for example,
So let's say for the value 55.
So we are searching for 55.
So here of course, this is a root node, we have only one entry element anyway, we cannot
do much.
So we just go to the right.
Here we have two elements, we might do binary search or we just compared and then we go
here.
But now what about, what about this next node?
So in my picture, of course, it only contains four nodes, but in reality, this could be
a thousand.
Let's pretend here that we have not four nodes, but we have a thousand.
Okay.
Oops, sorry, not 10,000, there's thousands.
So and of course we can do binary search, but can we do better?
And the answer is yes.
So why?
While traversing, we have seen that we are in a range that is larger than 49.
So I know that the smallest possible value that I have in my page is 49.
this because i walked to the right here so 49 is a lower bound and upper bound obviously is 58
because this is a separator that we went down and so therefore my page must contain values
between 49 and 58 okay and now what i could do is instead of doing a trivial binary search
i could try to interpolate basically i say my value here i'm searching for 58 55 so i then i
45 is six steps away from the lower bound of 49 and in total I have 58 minus 49 values.
So therefore I believe my position on this page will be this fraction.
And this will be then the approximate position on the page.
Approximate position.
And this is what we call interpolation search.
this is my page, instead of starting like a binary search in the middle, I take my key
that I have, so then of course I traverse down a tree and I have seen values that are
larger and smaller than me, so I traverse down a tree, this gave me up on lower bounds.
Then I take my value and I interpolate and I kind of could for example say,
if my distribution on a page is uniform, then I would expect my value to be here.
So for example here. So I go to this position.
Now, if I'm lucky, it's right, of course.
Could be that most likely it will not be right, at least not exactly right.
It will be roughly the right ballpark, but not exactly right.
So what I can do then, so I start here.
So what I do then is, I check, am I too small, am I too large?
So let's assume that the values that I currently found is to make some concrete example, let's
Let's say, if you're searching for 1150,
and the value here that I found is 1120.
So it's not totally wrong, but it's too small.
So what I do then is, I go one step to the right,
I go to look at the next element.
And this could be in this case be for example,
1125 or so.
Then I go, it's still too small.
Then I go two elements to the right.
this could be for example 1140 then I go four elements to the right you know
that I exponentially increase the step so and then this could be then say let's
say a hundred thousand one hundred seventy this is too large then in this
incident while now I do binary search so then I do binary search in this small
interval binary search okay so we guessed the first position by by
So this will bring me to roughly the correct position, not exactly the right position,
but roughly the correct position.
Then I do something that is called, if you look at Wikipedia, people call this exponential
search.
So I do exponentially increasing steps in the right direction until I find a range that
my value must contain and then I do binary search.
And of course this range is most likely much smaller than the full page, definitely much
smaller than the full page.
I will in many cases be faster than binary search.
So, and I, because my, if my,
the better my initial guess is,
so the closer my initial position is to my real position,
the faster the whole mechanism is.
So if I'm only one or two steps away, then it's perfect.
So I'm very, very fast.
If my interpolation doesn't work very well,
if my data is skewed, then it doesn't work that bad,
as it doesn't work that good,
but it doesn't matter that much
because we are still logarithmic in lookup cast.
Okay, so this is, so I see I'm running out of time for the, oops, running out of time
for the, for the insert, for the, for the Btree.
But so therefore we stop here, we're looking at the lookup, but I just want to drive this
point home.
Lookup performance is super important for two reasons.
Of course, first you do much more lookups than anything else.
Second all the other operations, insert, update and so on, they will always first do a lookup.
So therefore you want to spend effort
in making your look up fast.
And second, you must keep in mind your pages are large.
And as we can be, we store thousands of entries on a page
and therefore also the search within a page must be fast.
So the Btree by its algorithmic structure
allows you to look at only a few pages
or two or three pages,
but nevertheless the page itself
is a non-trivial data structure.
So we must manipulate the page itself quickly.
And so this is what you look at today.
So look up and in the next section, then we will continue and look at of course other
operations, insert, deletion and so on.
So thank you.
I will stop here for now.